so when we were talking about will and
jada you were blaming jada a lot okay
and i thought that was crossing the line
i thought you were going od on her and
then new footage came out
where you might be vindicated told joe
told y'all you might be vindicated which
play the footage witch sorceress
and i thought that might be a little bit
odd but this is the video that came out
where basically jade is filming will on
igbo
is coming to the table she's going to be
at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness if you
could stare come help us again please
i'm still dealing with foolishness don't
no no she yeah because she don't just
would you say
that she helped us heal the hurts that
we caused between one another my social
media presence is my bread and butter
okay so you can't just use me for social
media and not
you know don't just start bro i'm
standing in my house
don't just start rolling
please watch us stare at the red table
because she's helped us a lot can't you
tell
whoa oh
and then she came out and said she never
wanted to marry him that was like
another clip that came out that was why
yeah but she was like i was so i
regretted i cried on my wedding day the
only reason i did is because my mom
wanted me to do it blah blah i think the
only reason they did is because she got
pregnant yeah oh yeah that too yeah
yeah and then she don't love him you
know the birthday all that [ __ ] she
don't love him so now that ty's turning
all the comments i've seen on like every
will and jada post is like yeah yeah it
was her fault like she you know doesn't
deserve will blah blah blah yeah yeah we
knew that [ __ ] in 97.
yeah
it's wild corny to say social media is
my bread and butter
why that that line was wild corn my
social media presence is that's what he
should have said because he's protected
his image forever and now there's
someone on the outside having that power
and influence to promote
yeah
i think that's what he is no i think
it's corny for him to say that no but he
made it seem like social media like he's
new to instagram and all that like i
think he cares more about the 30 years
of i'm the biggest star in the world
social media press
stupid it's wild courtney just videotape
your husband right when you're beefing
yeah and bring up the beef like she
stinks she doesn't like him and
i mean she should just break up with him
like yo you don't like him why are you
putting him through that no it's will
need to leave her
will needs to leave her too but like she
also don't like him and she can't force
him to be with her so if you don't like
him don't do all this stuff but instead
she's taking out it looks from the
outside that she's abusing him
because of how angry she is that she's
in the relationship
like she's annoyed and feels pain for
being with someone that she doesn't want
to be with so she's treating that person
the way that she feels
see what i'm saying yeah yeah so
like leave that [ __ ] here's my
question about that video in particular
yeah everybody's pointed that video to
me that's the only time i've ever seen
him come close to standing up for
himself
where he you know the line i liked i'm
standing in my house he's gonna say our
house yeah he said i'm standing in my
house he said don't film me so like as
much as i don't like her that video
people like he seems so broken to me
it's like that's the if you think he's
broken there what about when he's
sitting with her at the [ __ ] red
table talking about her affair and
acting like oh yeah no this is cool i'm
cool with this that's when i thought he
was broken i was like that's [ __ ]
wild that you have to sit there and
justify her affair yeah on her tv show
that you pay for in your house so this
one you saw here is alpha i didn't think
he was alpha
relatively speaking
yes
yes that's what you would have done in a
situation
if i'm a guy who will slap another guy
for making a joke about her and she
doesn't like it that's alpha relatively
speaking i see what you're saying you're
judging him on like a will scale yes on
a wheel scale that says alpha as we've
seen will with jada ever don't just film
me without my permission yeah get out of
that bro and i get it's different like
you have children right like children
change everything but like
god damn both of y'all don't want to be
in this yeah
but for him to like overcome the
situation he's in does he is there a
race between the two of them to get to
he's got a he's got to leave her first
oh if he leaves her everybody will blame
jada like the best thing he could
possibly do with his career is leave her
and then he's the biggest star in the
world again you know i realized that i
was just in this thing that was super
toxic and i don't want to talk trash
about my kid's mother and i still love
her i'll always have love but like we
weren't in a relationship that was
bringing out the best of one another we
were trying to you know manipulate our
own emotions so we could keep this thing
going but the reality is we're not right
for each other and i wish her the best
he comes out and says
that we fill in all the blanks she's a
sorceress she's a witch she made us do
auditions that's the person
and then he comes out with a banger of a
movie he needs a banger of a movie as
well
oh no no yeah you gotta take the right
[ __ ] after you gotta have the right
girl and i don't know who it is who is
it but i don't know i've been trying to
figure this out
will smith who is the post divorce in
will smith well think about his his
female leads margot robbie margo
married like he's just got to go charlie
no no no no no
just get a baddie that no one knows
balds too lupita nuongo oh
he was with dandy newton
but nah
seven pounds who he was with rosario
dawson rosario who would the fresh
prince go with that's who that's what
he's gotta do yeah rosario he was with
tyra banks on the fresh prince oh yeah
yo get with sweetie
i'll be fired yeah that would be fine
somebody respect it what do you mean
he's like a beyonce oh yeah yeah yeah
well yeah that's what i'm saying that's
beyonce from jay son is that what you're
saying no no
maybe rihanna he could take riata there
you go
[Laughter]
she made an appearance publicly without
him she went to the shonda rhimes opened
like an art center or something like
that and then she went made a public
appearance without him it's like she
thinks she's famous without him she i
think she really believes she thinks she
would have still been famous i think she
never married women i think a little
part of her say you're out of your
[ __ ] mind
she wouldn't have been as famous but she
would still be name it three jada
pinkett smith movies before will she set
it off she said
set it off what else you seen woo
you seen [ __ ] woo i did see was she a
matrix i did see it matrix the after
will uh
i'm telling you i will turn that [ __ ]
down loki he did
he did and then he said hey jada take my
scraps
[Laughter]
the audacity of this girl she has done
nothing publicly to support him since he
slapped somebody for her you only have
to say i support the slack you could say
i don't support what he did but that's a
good man that's my husband i love him
hey it's healing season and then leaks
[ __ ] the source is like i don't need
protecting
yeah i think she said something like oh
like he messed things up or something
yeah randomly on twitter yeah apparently
she wanted to talk about until red table
talk your show the show that he paid for
for you to come [ __ ] on him every week
yeah but then he makes money in his
house
you think will can't make money
elsewhere you think will needs money
yeah i don't know if will needs is he
little bow wow
guy needs [ __ ] money
[Music]
he was talking crazy disrespect for the
bow wow yeah hey bella i'm sorry i'll
invite you to have my united 1k pass you
could take flights whenever you want to
i'll use points i'll get you
i'll get you first class dawg i got you
the disrespect yeah
i'm offering
you're about to find out how quick
that's a joke i guarantee you're not
giving no freaking you're flying
first class
i
you're going to give them all of your
miles yeah
all of them oh my god
you got my united states i have my
credit card points done come on i work
harder to make balance flight delayed
three days
i got you a delta flight anywhere you
want to go premium plus
well
i hope
i really truly hope that uh will can
find some peace
we want will back yes please
we'll come back and then you know what
jada might be happier and continue to do
great things with her life if they get
divorced too i believe the first part of
that she'd be happier maybe she'd be
happier maybe she wouldn't do good stuff
maybe she would but the point is
together both of their careers are
taking a huge hit and maybe a part
they'll be able to achieve the things
that they've always wanted
yeah
i think there should be a part i think
it'll give jayden some new material if
his parents get divorced i mean he has
some [ __ ] to write about the next album
will be a banger yeah
i mean willow's next emo album will be a
[ __ ] banger yeah that's a good point
but their music will probably slap more
i'm telling you dude this is a
win-win-win-win
everybody wins
you